- So wait, is it true that you
have a new passion in life?
Are you obsessed with ghosts?
I hear you are.
- It's not really a new passion.
- Okay, we're just finding out.
- You're just kind of
like finding out, yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah.
I feel like I've accepted
the fact that I see things
and I hear things.
- [Kelly] Wait, do you really?
You've had experiences.
- Yeah, a lot of them.
A lot of them over the years.
Even as a child growing up.
I remember being, like
getting ready for school
when I was eight years old
and there was like, you
know those ducks that like,
the duck thing that you pull, it's a toy.
- Yeah.
- There was one of those
on the dining room table
and I start walking
and it just started going alongside me
and I was like, interesting.
And I kind of shut it down for a while
because it's scary.
The unknown is scary.
So you can't
- Yeah.
- But I recently was
like, no, this is a gift,
and something that I
have the ability to do
so I'm gonna lean into
and I recently did my first
real paranormal investigation
like with equipment and everything.
- What equipment?
Like a flux capacitor?
What are we talking about here?
What kind of equipment?
- There's a lot.
There's so much on the market, genuinely.
- What?
- But my favorite thing
is called a spirit box.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And it basically scans radio
frequencies really quickly,
you wanna do it in more of a rural place
so it doesn't pick up stations,
and if you put it on AM it
just sounds like static.
But something about the
electricity that it creates
allows spirits to speak through it.
- I mean, the earth is all,
we do have frequencies.
- Exactly.
- It's own frequency.
- Okay.
- So I was sitting at a
tombstone in a graveyard
with my best friend.
- 'Cause that's what we do.
(Vanessa laughs)
- Well, if you're trying to find ghosts!
- Yeah!
- Go to the graveyard.
- Yeah.
Is this at nighttime or?
- Yeah, nighttime.
Pitch black.
- Wow, we're different.
(Vanessa laughs)
- And we found this one
tombstone of a spirit
that we were told is very playful.
So I turned it on.
I'm like "Hi, Sam.
I'm Vanessa.
This is Gigi."
I'm not very good at this,
I'm like "You're Sam."
- I am so into doing this, wow.
- And then Gigi goes, "Sam,
you can tell us our names?
What are our names?"
And then we just here "sshh Vanessa sshh."
- No.
No!
- Yeah.
- Did you run then?
- No.
(audience laughs)
No, I was like "Cool, do
you have anything else
that you wanna tell me?"
And I just hear "Sshh no."
And I was like okay,
cool, well, thank you.
You have to tell them to stay
because you don't want
spirits to follow you.
- Or do you?
- No, you don't.
(audience laughs)
- No.
We're trying to live like without that.
We don't need that all the time.
- That's crazy.
Okay.
If you were a ghost, do
you think you'd wanna,
I would follow people.
I'd just be nosy.
- I feel like I would be the ghost
that turns on Billie Holiday (laughs)
in the middle of the night.
- That doesn't sound
creepy at all. (laughs)
Old school music.
- I love creepy.